hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Arianna ba
serene Ariana and I today are gonna
check out from Billy on the street
Billy on the street Chris Pratt
lightning round let's see what this is
all about Ariana gave me a brief
explanation as to how Billy on the
street works yeah let's do it
we guys it's Billy a matter in the
streets of New York with my friend Chris
Pratt one of the biggest stars in the
world right now ready to hit the streets
to talk to New Yorkers about how excited
they are about Chris Pratt's career are
you ready okay
this is one of the biggest stars in the
world right now who is it I have no idea
oh my god it's Chris Pratt sorry it's
good you know guardians of the galaxy
biggest star in the world right now
Hollywood Reporter says who is this for
a dollar deadline says he's the bird
just the brightest leading man to come
along in years no Entertainment Weekly
says we finally we finally have a new
Han Solo after years of just Skywalker's
no okay thank you sir for a dollar for a
dollar deadline says he's the brightest
leading man to come along in years I
think he is yes looks real bright yeah
I'm looking guy look who it is
oh you're uh you're an actor yeah Liam
oh wow Renae guardians of the galaxy
Jurassic world I don't think anything
you've ever shown me is made me like
more happy earth yeah
I needed that video not even wanted to
end I love that Chris Brad like
desperately yeah me me I love it when
celebrities are willing to poke fun at
themself oh yeah and so vulnerable to be
like this he's like a huge movie star
yeah literally and they're just like I
love it and I like that Renee is just
like this new york lady she's like oh
hey chris pratt nice to meet you yeah
like she's so not these people like that
all the time or something that was such
a real life cuz i i'll be honest guys i
wasn't having like a the brightest
morning can so being able to watch a
video like this it's nice to be like my
spirits feel really uplift my face hurts
from smiling
I thought it was [ __ ] hilarious
watching Chris Pratt like just be so
gung-ho for it looking at the people and
the billion guys this is [ __ ]
hilarious like if they get one thing
wrong you just flips out I love that vh1
oh that's the best way to like do that
kind of bit I think because there's
other ways where you they probably
didn't like do you know this is and
that's it the fact that he was like
emotional and really high dollar yeah
that was fantastic Oh Chris Pratt I love
my Chris prior unless Chris Pratt I
loved you when you were fat now I love
you when you're cut either way you're
[ __ ] awesome cut he's cut now I know
sexy yeah you sexy now I know probably
is a huge [ __ ] I mean it'll chills
thinking about Chris Pratt
all right Phyllis Phyllis oh okay
I felt it you turned on no yeah how it
goes anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects and become a reject akan is that
way okay and get uh Orianna badass DUP
sounds like I'm telling people who do a
stuff okay I'm sorry
get are you ask are you know in my honor
everyone go out and do something ass
related go do that stuff in her honor
you know what I mean as long as you put
on this tone of voice it could be
anything nasty you know what I mean
Daniel Davis hi real rejects wanted to
say I thoroughly enjoy your content you
make video reacting and movie reviews
seem easier to do instead of a kinky
prostitute you mint or nope I'm gonna be
polite
sorry for this but I would like a shout
out hi Veronica person who won't be
named cos are not on the channel anymore
ELISA brandy Cassandra Samantha Noel and
Jerry I want my shout out to be in a
funny rap form so I can quote it in my
untitled future of comedy mixtape I know
at least one pretty girl the cover
should be connected to this post now to
go away from my dad a comeback it's like
he's putting together a song and he just
wants some type of thing all right
Ariana busted be okay cherish me
connected to the poet's finest a I
thought they are just clapper
other than that ah dude Daniel Davis
you're gonna be courageous when you're
hanging out with a navy prostitute you
got to do this cuz you're a damn nasty
dude you want to go around here you're
behaving so rude to all these
prostitutes you behave so crude but
guess what man I give a shout-out to
Alyssa
Cassandra Samantha no well Jerry and
Brandi hey it's so much hilarity on
though real rejects so never forget that
you came by this channel welcome to the
panel Daniel I want you to know that I
love you and hey you're black that's
right it's a fact
I like black dudes cuz it makes me not
seem like I'm a voracious dude I like
black people I love black people
she went to an all black strip club I
did I was like missed out